but we're going to begin today
unfortunately with new details from
Allen Texas the scene of that horrific
mass shooting on Saturday the gunman's
motive is still very unclear but CBS
News has learned he showed an interest
in races far-right ideology that was
before gunning down eight people at an
outlet mall who just got up on a
Saturday to go shopping we're also
learning more about some of the eight
victims including a family that lost
nearly everybody Omar villafranco's in
Allen Texas and more on the story and
Omar this is a part where you start
hearing about the victims and this is a
stop time where it gets really real that
little six-year-old boy is the only sole
survivor I can't stop thinking about
that this morning what else are we
learning today
good morning Gail we're learning more
about the victims and their ages they
were young ages 3 to 37 years old
investigators are also now trying to
piece together the movements of the
shooter in the weeks before to see if
something set him off on this rampage
now we want to warn you some of the
descriptions you're about to hear are
graphic but survivors told us they want
people to hear this because it's the
truth and they want the mass shootings
to stop
and the gunshots just it sounded like a
war zone it it was horrifying Raquel Lee
was one of the countless terrified
people at the Allen Premium Outlets mall
when the bullets started flying Saturday
she said she hid inside a bathroom
closet crying and praying when I was
crouching down like oh we don't get hit
by a bullet but at least eight others
were shot and killed including three
members of The Cho family mom Cindy dead
q and their three-year-old son James the
Lone Survivor was their six-year-old son
William who was wounded during the
shooting also among the dead two young
sisters fourth grader Daniela Mendoza
and second grader Sophia Mendoza 20 year
old security guard Christian lacour 26
year old engineer from India ashwara
thadacanda and 32 year old Elio kumana
Rivas
yesterday mourners gathered at a
makeshift Memorial outside the mall to
pay their respects we put flowers we
said a prayer but it's just not enough
we need legislation to change
our gun loss an army official tells CBS
News the 33-year-old gunman Mauricio
Garcia was terminated from the Army in
2008 for mental health reasons he later
became an armed licensed security guard
certified by the Texas Department of
Public Safety working for three security
companies between 2016 and 2020 where he
received firearms training and passed a
background check
his internet searches indicate he was
very interested in far-right and white
supremacist ideology
though it is not yet known if this
served as a motive for the shooting
there was an atrocious amount of blood
muscle tissue Etc Navy veteran Joshua
Barnwell was shopping for jeans at the
mall when the gunfire broke out he says
he rushed to the aid of those who had
been shot this is my hope that at least
if not for anything even if I lost the
victims there was somebody there that
was speaking to them they just weren't
lying there by their Lonesome with their
final thoughts being
I was here to buy sandals and shorts
with my kid and now here I am
law enforcement sources say the shooter
had an AR style rifle and several
magazines and a handgun on him and he
also had five other weapons in the car
six people remain in the hospital Tony
just atrocious details Omar thank you
very much